[Music]
we're going to be talking about APM
monitoring for connected customer
experiences so I'll be the co-host today
fruitball Bogle I'm part of the Apogee
product team it's nothing but a pleasure
to have you folks attend this session
this morning been with the Apple II team
for little over five years and a dry of
few different areas for the product team
including API monitoring and super
excited to have Luke join us here from
urban science and he's my partner in
crime for today's session and he will
also walk us through the urban science
story and how they're leveraging
benefits from the API monitoring
capability that we just about to talk
about okay excellent with that some
basic housekeeping so this year at next
we have the ability for the attendees to
be able to ask questions on the Dory Q&A
link you should be able to find that in
your Google next app so please feel free
to ask any questions out there we also
have two microphones up here as well and
we'll save some time towards the end for
some Q&A live and and both Dory as well
okay so just a brief recap of the agenda
we will talk a little bit about why API
monitoring has become so critical we'll
talk about some of the common solutions
which are available in the market today
and how the integrated API monitoring is
different and then we'll actually hear
life from Luke about urban science
historian how they've kind of achieved
the benefits from that solution okay so
if I was to do a quick poll out here
hominid out here in the audience think
they've used at least one API today on
the way to this conference
it's got to be everyone who burr ordered
something okay so ap are becoming
mainstream right
to me there is no power there's no more
powerful fact than saying it's entered
our each and every day life
on a daily basis you're probably hearing
more than five to ten api's at a minimum
in this world when people are talking
about data transformation enterprises
are morphing them themselves into
entities where the products are nothing
but api's so if you transact your
capabilities as api's with your
employees with your partner's api has
become extremely critical in how you are
perceived in a marketplace for us
personally
we pride in poverty
api program for many of our key
customers and I'm really happy to talk
about that we have nearly doubled our
API traffic since since March of last
year this is the amount of API traffic
that we serve just alone from our cloud
platform so let's talk a little bit
about because API have become so front
and center of an enterprises face out
there in this world what that means is
operationally the teams have to be on
top of ensuring that api's are
performing the way they should so no
longer is it ok for you to find out
after the fact that hey my a PS was a PS
were down because it has downstream in
fact of affecting many of your partners
who may be banking on EAP has to deliver
connected experiences of their own so
Ops teams need to be able to monitor
api's in real time and more importantly
have the ability to identify issues
before the consumers of the API realize
that there are some issues out there
that's a very important aspect and as
you start to look to some of these
features you also want to be able to
quickly diagnose where the issues are so
that you can lower the mean time to
resolution now we do have many customers
and when I talk to them they use several
tools out there today to be able to get
a sense of is something broken and what
we find out
in talking to them that synthetic
monitoring tools just aren't enough and
what i mean by that is d the typical api
monitoring tools which are sitting
outside the platform using some probes
to be able to gather some key metrics
such as suddenly there is a high amount
or error rate in an api or your latency
just went up so they can tell you what's
broken
of course they serve a purpose the key
point is they are not correlated with
some of the other things that you need
to be able to perform useful forensics
such as can I go take a look at the log
file right now at this moment to
understand you know can I correlate that
with a specific error so these tools
tell you what's broken but they don't
really give you the inserts into where
it's broken so you can quickly fix what
you need to so epi G's API monitoring is
an integrated API monitoring solution
what we also called as a white box API
monitoring solution and so one of the
key advantages of it being integrated
into the platform is the ability for it
to be able to give you contextual
insights into your API issues so let's
say that example if we have an error a
higher error rate in an API suddenly
you're able to through a dashboard
visualize what the error is and then do
contextual drilldowns to find out the
source of the error and also do some
determinism on how widespread the error
is and actually I will be showing that
to you in a quick demo but the fact of
having API monitoring integrated into
the platform not only gives us the
contextual insights that we can deliver
to you our customers but more
importantly it opens up some very
interesting possibilities which are just
not possible through a synthetic
monitoring solution such as imagine a
scenario where you are the operational
team and you have you're using the a pH
platform as an example to survey api's
to your consumers and let's say for
those of our
here just a quick show of hands how many
users in the audience have used a pudgy
edge before okay
quite a few so a pudgy edge is a full
lifecycle API management platform and
you can use out-of-the-box policies to
do things like traffic management let's
let's imagine a scenario whenever you've
used one of the spy chorus policies to
limit the amount of traffic to one or
more api's and you have said it to a
threshold let's say a thousand per
minute and maybe that serves you know
okay for your needs and suddenly there's
a catastrophe failure in your backends
the back ends which are back into the
API proxies and you want to be able to
very quickly shut off traffic to them
well one choice is you can go and update
all the spy chorus policies one by one
depending on the number of API proxies
but by that time your backends may not
be able to survive so how about if
you're able to leverage the power of the
platform and this is something we are
working on and we give you operator
controls to be able to dial down the
traffic to all the api's at once that is
what we mean by the close to aspect of
the integrated API monitoring that is
very powerful and that is something
which a synthetic monitoring tool can
never provide to you so FPGA peer
monitoring as I mentioned is integrated
into the platform leverages the best of
Google tech we have some icons out here
just a quick sampling of the underlying
tech that we use to power these
capabilities and deliver it to our
customers precision diagnostics I'll
just spend a very few seconds on this
this is a very important piece of
lowering your mean time to diagnostics
and this ties into what I just mentioned
of course tools can tell you what's
broken but we tell you where it's broken
I'll show that to you in a few minutes
contextual insights this is essentially
where once an issue on an error is
detected how do you really take that
drill down through different aspects and
get the right level of insight which
becomes very important for you to
resolve that issue once and for
with that let me just quickly get into a
demo if we can switch awesome so this is
my beautiful Gmail background so you can
see imagine in this case that I am the
ops person on a schedule and I've just
kind of recently received an alert so
from my perspective I want to be able to
go in and I can see that there's a alert
which was fired for high latency and
this alert tells me what's going on you
can see the organization within Apogee
that's encountering the error it tells
me that it's sustained you know latency
above what our threshold is and so I
would like to go and take a look at that
once I click on View details and I'm
hoping the demo guards of this today
looks like they are ok so this is the
very first entry point
I gotta alert and I came in and right
away I can see that there are some
issues with latency so this alert kind
of gives me some insight into what's
going on but more importantly as I start
to scroll down these panels start to
give you some more deeper insight so in
this case as an example I can see that
this particular proxy the one which I
got loaded for has some high number of
errors and I can click on one of the
cells out here to go and figure out
what's going on so in this case it
starts to give me some insights into the
total latency and where the error could
be now this alert is extremely powerful
for me to take a peek on what's going on
but I would like to go and investigate
this thing a little bit more so if I
click on the investigate tab this starts
to give me what I mean by the broad
spectrum aspects of the platform so in
this case I can see that there are
different kinds of dimensions that I can
compare against if you provide three
different panels here so I can compare
fault code which could be something
coming right out of an API proxy may
be written up a new policy and that
through an error I see a very high
number of invalid access token errors
out here so as the operator i'm really
curious i want to be able to click on
this time zone and then drill down what
it tells me is that there's a specific
API proxy in this case the one that I
got alerted on that is having this error
but also out here if we have developer
applications which are consuming it you
start to get a distribution by not only
the developer app but also by the target
back in three hitting this is very
powerful because not only can I do this
kind of analysis but more importantly I
can go out here and also examine the
logs and this is what I meant by
contextual insights and drill down
typically we see customers doing this
thing from a combination of two or three
different tools you may get a loaded of
an issue you may then go and determine
that I need to go find out and correlate
the logs well in this case you have all
that information at your fingertips so
in this case I now start getting some
pretty detailed information about where
the error is coming from which API proxy
you know and I also more importantly
have a message ID that can be used to
correlate across other systems right so
this is just a very simple example of
how you can use these capabilities
additionally we have also integrated
custom reporting into into this tool and
so we talk to customers they examine
this very classical real time to
trending continuum and what that means
is of course they want to be alerted in
real-time but they also want to be able
to then navigate to perhaps a time frame
when the error actually start occurring
and this is a very common scenario in
use cases where let's say you deploy an
API proxy okay and let's say your
latency threshold happens to be 10
seconds right but this API proxy
deployed starts to creep up over five
seconds six seconds slowly over a period
of time you just happen to notice it the
second week that it crept over ten
seconds you got a letter
but this
continuum of real-time - trending now
gives you the ability to be able to
navigate that and see when the error
actually occurred you just got a loaded
of this thing right now but that gives
you deeper insights into when that
happen so I'll just cover up couple of
screens real quick out here this is the
the dashboard view where you can get
some high-level access into the total
traffic the api's which have the top
number of errors top Layton sees and
then you can look into different aspects
out here collections are aware of
grouping certain ApS together what we
have found is we have several of our
customers who have operational teams who
own those api's they may be a central
operation scenes who want to be the
dispatcher if you would but then they
monitor groups of API with certain
characteristics you can do that easily
with collections another view I would
like to talk about is the recent view in
this case this is very this is a very
interesting view where you can do what
we call is knock like analysis right
like a network operation center so in
this case this heat map view gives you a
peek into what's going on what's wrong
and if I click on this environment as an
example double click on this it now
starts to give me a drill down or
different API proxies so I can come from
the top and see something is an error
but then very quickly start to drill on
certain scenarios on certain API proxies
and then being able to kind of examine
all the contextual information ok so
think of this as the something is wrong
at a high level I can drill drill drill
and go to the parts and figure out
what's broken the last part I want to
show out here is the alerting capability
the the fact that I got an alert from
something out here is something that you
can easily configure so here's an
example of the alert that we have
configured that fired in this case again
we have some pretty interesting
heuristics you can go and do a loading
on different metrics in this case
latency but you can pick status codes
fault codes which may be emanating from
certain proxies and more importantly you
can see this pretty interesting chart
they bit out here is called the the
condition data so
this gives you as the operator the
ability to set the alert at the right
level so that is not too noisy so we
aggregate information give you what the
what the latency is and you can see the
the chart and determine well I really
want to get notified at this point in
time okay so with this I'm going to if
we can switch back to the presentation
please awesome so with that I would like
to invite Luke up to the stage here and
Luke please share your story thank you
thank you everybody thank you for the
opportunity to speak today I'm gonna
take you guys through a little bit about
our experience in urban science and how
we got to where we're at today which is
a really good spot we have over 650
api's in production running right now
we're producing anywhere from 8 to 10
million transactions a month and growing
on a regular basis a little bit about me
I've been with urban signs for about 10
years now working inside the customer
space so all of our stuff is PII related
really sensitive data that we have to
deal with who we are at urban science
were we we'd like data we're all about
data we're all about big data and we use
that data to solve our clients
mission-critical problems our clients
we're in the Motor City they're pretty
much all automotive right now we're
moving into retail and health as we
speak what we do is we listen to our
partners and they tell us what they they
need we help them solve their mission
critical problems and we do that with
the data and with the api's that we have
we're everywhere if you've bought a car
looked at the car thought about buying a
car rode in a car you've probably
touched our software we've probably
touched your records at some point or
now they're a little map where we are so
what do we do so what we do at urban
science is we listen to our customers we
solve our customers problems and we do
it with data and we do it loyalty and we
do it repeatedly and we do it right
every single time we do it to drive
their profits and we have a really
unique vantage point at urban science
because we can we can see the whole
ecosystem we see the whole industry and
we see it really broadly and really deep
across the whole thing we can optimize
dealer networks and we use that
optimizations to drive their marketing
efforts their position of their of their
locations again pretty much anything in
the automotive space if you've bought a
car or looked at
car you've probably you've touched our
software so what do we do
I run the c4 marketing intelligence
cloud that is a customer centric market
intelligence cloud to drive marketing
into the automotive space and we do it
all with data for fall indicate earlier
that a lot of customers and a lot of
businesses are going to API products
that's exactly what our marketing
intelligence cloud is it is just an API
product we have no real front-end we
have a bunch of API is over 650 of them
right now and we've integrated heavily
with Google in the apogee product to
help us do that what we've done is we've
taken their products we've created the
dev portal I'm going to take you through
the dev portal show you how we kind of
structured that a little bit and then
take you into our API management
platform and show you where my ops
team's live their lives every single day
I'm gonna take you into our real life
system so you can see exactly what's
going on so we do all of everything we
do and we do it to empower our marketing
to drive business inside the automotive
space and to increase our shopper
experience that happens again in real
time and so we have millions of
transactions flowing through this API
management platform that's transacting
with PII data in some cases and a lot of
really highly sensitive data so secured
it was really important for us which is
one of the primary reasons that we chose
Apogee and API management we didn't want
to write that security later we needed
authentication authorization access and
auditing and we needed that because of
the customer centric approach that we
were taken so our API program basically
we had to figure out why we want to do
API so about 2016 we started down the
the track of digital transformation
right you guys have heard it all all day
every day for the last couple days we
needed to build a platform that would be
used industry-wide but we didn't want to
build the solutions right we wanted to
build a platform that would empower
other companies other internal teams to
build those solutions we had access to
the data all that data the breadth and
the width of data was very valuable but
inaccessible so we needed to open it up
we needed to open it up and make it
accessible we needed to expose that data
both internally to other development
science as well as external partners
marketing agencies if you guys were at
some of the other sessions with violent
we've done a lot of stuff to empower
marketing agencies with some of this
data as well but not only do we need to
make it expose we need to make it easy
you know terabytes and terabytes of data
moving around automotives a pretty
legacy industry boy they love their flat
files so but they don't work you can't
move the data fast enough at a high
enough velocity without exposing some
sort of API interface our customers they
were all like the internal and external
both data providers and data consumers
and so we not only very pay a platform
half to expose data right but it also
had to ingest an ingress additional data
from other providers other teams within
urban science and other teams externally
so we needed api's on the front end to
collect that data and then api's on the
back end also an egress it back out so
why do we choose Apogee back in 16 it
was before they were bought by Google
actually I think we bought we partnered
with averaging they're like a two weeks
later we learned that Google acquired
them so I'm like I heard that like good
decision but we needed and we need it
and we required proper mature API
management not I I think I understand
api's but real API management somebody
who understood the needs of the security
the needs of of the auditing and the
analytics we needed something that was
easy easy to build easy maintain and
easy for developers to get access to we
didn't want to reinvent the wheel we
didn't want to build all of that
infrastructure we wanted to focus on
building our micro services our API and
get them out to market and again we
didn't want to create that secure later
I know it sounds like a broken record
but that security layer is super super
important it's a sensitivity of the data
so the seafloor market intelligence
cloud that is our API product today
fully integrate with Apogee we've like I
said we have over 650 API is published
doing anywhere from 8 to 11.5 million a
month it abscent flows if you run an API
program or or monitor or watch one you
know you hit those milestones right in
2016 we had our first dollars in
transaction days
thousand transactions and a few weeks
later was like a hundred thousand and
then it was like five hundred thousand
that was like million it's like finally
I'm like oh man five million we're gonna
need some more infrastructure so I'm
really happy to hear what they announced
earlier today it's gonna be great made
my life way easier so what are some of
our benefits and why it matters you know
bird box VLC is a great movie right
fantastic but being blind is terrible
it's absolutely terrible and without
property management we were completely
blind to what was going on in the system
we couldn't see what our customers were
seeing we couldn't see what our
developers were experiencing so we were
completely buying we needed that
real-time visibility into our production
API behaviors so that we could respond
proactively as opposed to waiting for
the telephone call from an angry
development team saying hey guys your
stuffs broken those calls are terrible
if you're an app's team we need an API
management to allow our teams to view
that real-time usage so that we can make
critical proactive decisions about scale
when you're at a thousand transactions a
day that's a lot different than a
thousand transactions a second right and
the underlying infrastructure that
required that's required to run that it
matters so some of the challenges that
we experienced before we put that
monitoring in place and before Appaji
introduced API monitoring again we were
blind the clients would let us know I
think the worst day was when I had three
or four development teams to internal
and one external send us emails telling
us that the API for five hundred okay
guys we can't do this like that's that's
terrible we need to know exactly what's
going on inside our systems and then we
were we're also guessing so we guessed a
lot about what the traffic patterns were
gonna look like what the scale is gonna
look like you know we had tools that
helped us understand that but we didn't
see it in real time and API monitoring
when they released it out and my ops
team kind of stumbled upon it inside the
the management suite
oh man goodness that is fantastic let's
get into some of that and it became the
space where my team lived and so that's
what I'm gonna take you through right
now
I'm switching over to the demo we will
take you through kind of our journey and
how we got to where we're at so first
and foremost with a with the API
management tool that Apogee provides
they give you a development for it was
great I didn't have career
my team to have created website we
configured a website we productized the
API is in Apogee management studio and
then we expose them to developers it was
fantastic
so what we got here is basic API portal
and I'm gonna jump right into our API
Docs and when we jump into our API Docs
this guy so here we have a set of
productized api's that are publicly
available for anyone to request access
to our model doesn't require that
doesn't allow for just ad-hoc consumer
integration so you have to become a
partner with urban science will then
issue you a key but anybody can go and
look at these if you actually want to
get into the real data you're gonna have
to you know send an email make a call
will issue a key it's all super secure
but these are our basic attribution
products that we have again these are a
small subset of publicly available api's
we have a large set of privately
available api it's in a large set of
partner available api is that that we've
exposed again all of this information on
the dev portal actually driven through
the API management studio based on the
product is asian of the work that the
ops team has done so we have all these
api's that are out here that are
available for someone to integrate with
and learn more and you can drill down
into the swagger docs and learn all the
contracts and all that stuff but I'm
gonna take you through next is our API
monitoring I'm gonna jump right into the
API monitoring dashboard for our
marketing intelligence cloud you can see
we've got a couple different proxies
that are running right now but this is
where my ops team's lives so we've got
all of those api's that are out there
that are public and productized what
we've done is we've created a set of
collections that speak to those
attribution API so these are we've
created an attribution apps and what
we've done is not everything is as
important as everything right so some of
our API products are far more important
than others we have over 650 of which
some of them are very low consumer some
of them are administration some of them
are customer oriented so we've got
really a couple really big key api
products that are important to us and to
our customers and so we've collection.i
those we've created collections out of
them and we've made them a little bit
more
if you will and so once we've got our
collection set up then we've gone in and
we've made a series of alerts and you
can see our alerts here we've got quite
a bit of them we have a little say in an
urban sign so we like it's basically
five over five so if you've got five 5
acts there's over five minutes and it
repeats you're gonna have a problem 5 5
X there's over 5 minutes that doesn't
repeat latency issue connectivity issues
somebody's having you know a couple of
hiccups or whatever
most of those they end up triaging and
they end up self resolving and we don't
really worry about them but if if we get
5 over 5 repeatedly then we have a
problem we need to go into what
pathology earlier more that deep
analysis about root cause about why why
the air curd and what's actually going
on so we've got you know that collection
of api's that we created and then we've
turned those into an alert for the
attribution 5 X errors and then that
allows us to then subscribe to those
alerts and my team like I said they live
inside this API monitoring space we just
liked we're all told you we have the the
alerts that come in the email for
proactive responses we have a lot of
different things that this tooling has
empowered our team to be really visible
and see what's going on and and helped
us evolve from hey we should do api's to
a hundred transactional API to over a
million over 10 million a month with the
same exact ops team so we've continued
to scale the infrastructure we continue
to scale the system and with this
tooling in place we've been able to
maintain that small operational team
while also maintaining a high customer
satisfaction
yeah well the pretty much wraps up all
of my demo I think we've got about 20
minutes or so for questions per thought
like to invite you to come back up and
and we can take it from there
sure thank you so much Luke that was a
great demo so thanks for taking us
through that and I think do you had a
couple other dashboards out here but I
think one of the I'm just gonna start
summarizing it here in a few but I just
want to go back to the demo that he just
did I think that was a great
example of how in real life you know
urban science is using API monitoring to
stay ahead of what the customers are
experiencing and that was a very
powerful statement he he said that we
want to be able to experience and see
what our customers are experiencing
there's another example of how API
monitoring gives you the tools to be
able to be proactive determine what's
going on and quickly mitigate some of
those issues some of the alerting that
Lucas took us through graciously was
also a mechanism to kind of get alerted
on the channel of your choice so as an
example you know we saw emails which
were you know that I got but again you
can use different notification channels
such as pager duty slack or pretty much
anything out there which other webbook
the picture that you see out here again
is an extract from there - were out here
which gives you the drill down
capability that we were talking about
[Music]